Resident Evil 2 is scaring a whole new
generation of gamers with a remake that
is arguably even more frightening than
its first era ratio the game stars Leon
s Kennedy and Claire Redfield as they
attempt to make their way out of a
zombie infested Raccoon City whilst in
the original version of the game the
massive monster mr. X didn't appear
until scenario B in the new reboot he is
on your tail straight away stalking you
throughout the corridors of the RPD and
not even giving you a break to finish
off a puzzle or two but what is his
history and where did he come from well
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the mysterious man there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you don't want
to know anything about the character
then I highly suggest that he turn off
now but with that out the way I'm
definition and welcome to the channel
where I play it so you don't have to mr.
X also known as the tyrant II 103 was
sent into Raccoon City in 1998 along
with five other versions of the tyrant X
was primarily tasked with retrieving a
sample of the g-virus from Sheri Birkin
and to kill the remaining survivors of
the RPD something that puts him directly
into the path of Leon Kennedy when X is
dropped into the RPD of the majority of
the officers are dead and when Sheri
escapes into the sewers he follows her
Claire Leon and ADA Wong down there in
the original Resident Evil 2 after
falling into molten metal t 103 suffered
serious burns but managed to climb out
of the fiery pit X becomes one of the
game's final bosses when he mutates into
his tyrant form and loses his jacket
luckily the survivors were able to kill
him with a rocket launcher and escape
onto the train where they were
confronted by the most mutated form of
William Birkin in the remake ex wears a
fedora at some points to emphasize his
covert operation and though it does make
him look a bit like odd job just just
don't tell him I said that X of course
was the inspiration behind the nemesis
which appears in Resident Evil 3 and
this two stock characters
attempting to kill them but to be honest
I find mr. Rex much more scary unlike
the original game however the remake
sees mr. X talking you of his own free
will
similar to the xenomorph from alien
isolation X can now move about freely in
the game instead of set pieces that he
was confined to in its first version
this freedom of movement makes him
infinitely more dangerous and it's no
surprise that players are calling him
the scariest game monster ever
over the years mr. X has kept relatively
the same appearance with his trench coat
being the most noticeable thing about
him in addition to Resident Evil 2 he
has appeared in gun survivor the
darkside Chronicles and operation
Raccoon City obviously Resident Evil 2
will thrust the character back into the
limelight and I can't wait to see fan
reactions to the new version of him so
are you excited or terrified to see the
return of mr. X are you enjoying
Resident Evil 2 and what's your favorite
one in the series comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of last year's big game
Red Dead Redemption to you which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
the hardcore players so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace Resident Evil 2 okay I
could never do that voice all the way
Resident Evil 2 resident look someone do
their best Resident Evil - voice in the
comments yeah Cheers
you